this is me at works at home at the
dentist on vacation at the park in my
history I can find all of the places
I've been in the last few days the last
few weeks even the last few months
nothing is missing
I wondered how Google could follow me so
precisely so I asked them Google replied
we use various technologies to look at
you including IP address GPS signals and
other sensors that allow us to identify
particular devices Wi-Fi access points
and cell towers in the vicinity I can
disable this history but Google tells me
this does not delete the data it
contains neither doesn't disable the
updating of the position GPS and Wi-Fi
location services of your device it
isn't just Google tracking my location
of my 57 apps 31 have continuous access
to my location this is useful for
getting the bus schedule or to count how
many steps I've taken today but with my
flashlight app my games or my newspaper
tracks where I'm drinking my morning
coffee
that's not something that's very useful
to me but it certainly is to advertisers
members of The Guardian project who
helps citizens and activists protect
data that's on the phones explains me
how it works
the most fundamental information that
someone can find out about you from your
phone is actually comes from the phone
part of the smart phone as you move
through a city it's constantly pinging
to find the best Tower or being told hey
connect to this tower or negotiating a
triangulation constantly broadcasting a
beacon of view of your phone's unique
identifier it's unique in the planet
once you connect the identify of your
phone and the SIM card which is your
subscriber identifier the way you pay
for things
those numbers are combined and sent to
the phone company and then that's logged
as a way to charge you right for payment
and then once you get into the
smartphone layer just think of all the
the sensors the that we use to make sure
we stay fit and track our lives now all
of that data is stored on your phone
logged in your photos or in unencrypted
databases data which paints a picture of
you your day what you're interested in
where you've been who you've talked to
this is a goldmine of information for
people that want to sell you things
obviously for people that want to
monitor the state of their nation or
their company or whatever body they
manage you know this is also very useful
information and then for someone who's
trying to do targeted surveillance of
you if you are under investigation
essentially your pre bugged your pre
tabs if the police came and said we're
going to put a camera in your living
room in your bathroom and your bedroom
and on your backpacking in your hat or
not going to turn them on unless you
commit a crime I don't think people
would let that happen but we have that's
what these the phones essentially when
you use your phone's Wi-Fi in the public
place you're sending out a lot of
information about yourself you'll see
how it works in our next video every
morning I go to a cafe and order a
coffee for son I connect to the Wi-Fi
before I even open the newspaper usually
it's free